there's been a lot of talk about
artificial intelligence this year at
Davos and artificial intelligence is not
a technology in and of itself it's the
use of technologies to model humans or
to make machines that act like humans
there seems to be a tremendous amount of
fear about artificial intelligence right
now is it going to take over the world
are we going to create killer robots
while autonomy is an important concept
in artificial intelligence
interdependence is an important concept
in the real world
I build therefore social artificial
intelligence I endow machines with the
ability to interact with people the way
people interact with one another it's
really difficult to understand the
minutiae of how people interact with
other people with such attention to
detail that we can build those same
skills into a machine it's important
however we understand the intelligence
not just of modeling our ability to work
in a factory for example but also
understanding and endowing machines with
the ability to interact and collaborate
with people